this next one I'm going to give you a
few minutes to think about this one and
it's funny because it's a um it's a
property that honestly just sounds
strange but I've become a little
obsessed with it over the last couple
months when I say the Ang on a
semi-circle do you recognize this
property do you know what this means
oh if you don't it's okay I'll just show
it to you but I yeah that's fine so
um draw a rough Circle for me
um and you can see how big it is on my
page I just don't want to make it too
small and it doesn't have to be an exact
Circle I'm not expecting you to get a
pair of compasses out but it needs to
look vaguely circular otherwise you
won't see what's going on okay
this property is called the angle on a
semicircle because if you take your
circle and then just slice it in half
anywhere you like right so I'm gonna
find a spot and then I'm gonna draw a
diameter okay that looks that looks like
a diameter
yep okay now what's great is if you draw
this diameter and now find any point on
the circumference just literally
randomly pick a point on the
circumference
I'm going to put one up here okay
if you've got a diameter which gives you
two semicircles and then you just pick
any point on the diameter look up for a
second as I draw this bit and then
you're going to draw it too watch what
happens when I make what we call the
angle in a semicircle
there we go and maybe once you draw your
own one which I presume is going to be
in a different spot right you might
notice there's something in common
between my angle and your angle it's a
special angle
how big does it look
[Applause]
90 degrees it looks pretty right angled
to me right and in fact it is if you've
got uh the the diameter there whichever
angle you try and make on the
circumference and I'll make a few more
now just to show you it always works
right here's another one over here
like so another right angle let me draw
like a weird one just a small one over
here
they're all right angles okay so the
angle in a semicircle is always 90
degrees
now this is a really fantastic property
because not only is it
um true its Converse is also true now
I'm going to give you a moment just to
try and prove that if you know I'll get
rid of the other ones here let's just go
with a simple diagram like so I want you
to try and prove in any way that you
like and I promise it's actually pretty
easy I'll even give you a clue which is
I'm drawing the center somewhere because
the diameter has to go through the
center right let me give you a couple of
minutes just on your own to see if you
can work out how might you prove that
this angle up in the corner is 90
degrees I'll give you a moment and then
I will um I'll show you a really quick
proof okay have a go
yeah yeah it's It's Tricky when like
this is one of the hard Parts about
deductive geometry I I remember is that
when you look at something if you stare
at it and don't see it immediately
unlike say in algebra where you're like
I don't know I'll just expand some stuff
or I'll just you know um start canceling
things wherever I can unlike that with
geometry I feel like sometimes you kind
of need an Insight like a spark and then
once you see it I mean you saw it with
this previous question right you're like
oh I see what's going on and then the
rest of it became obvious when you don't
see it you're like oh where do I go okay
so I will I'll give you a nudge because
it's not too challenging right
um once you know what to do with it I'm
going to draw in an extra radius here
like so now one of the great things that
happens in a circle is because you've
got radii going everywhere you've got
lots of equal lengths and lots of equal
angles so if for example you look up the
top here I've got an isosceles triangle
so if I looked at its angles like if I
call this Alpha for instance there's
another angle that's Alpha which one is
it uh the one top right top right
fantastic so it's this one here right
but this is not the only isosceles
triangle that I've made right there's
also the the sort of obtuse uh isosceles
triangles so it's it's sort of equal to
this side right now again you've got
these two angles that are equal if I
call
um say this one beta in the corner
where's the other beta
um
next to Alpha very good yeah up the top
next to Alpha okay so that's beta there
now can you see between my alphas and my
betas I have filled in every angle in
this triangle do you see that and so
what I can say is oh
um if you put together all the angles
you'll get two alpha plus two beta but
what's the angle sum of a triangle
oh hold on a triangle
that's okay I tricked you because we
were looking at quadrilaterals just now
so you're in quadrilateral mode that's
totally fine that's right so so we've
got 180 but can you see what I can do
here I can just divide through by two
and that gives me the alpha plus beta
that's in the corner
yeah that's right that's the 90 degrees
okay now this obviously is not a vector
proof okay but we're going to use
vectors to prove What's called the
converse have you done you've done
nature of proof haven't you
yeah we've done it yep so if you
remember
um a Converse is if you know that a
implies B the converse is the other way
around right so B implies a this this
thing here is the converse okay so what
I'm saying is we just proved that if
you've got a diameter
then um you have to get a right angle
right so the converse with that would be
if you've got a right angle you must
have the diameter okay so we're going to
prove this we're going to use vectors to
do it it's a really clever proof uh I
didn't make it up myself almost all the
clever things that I've ever done in
maths someone else showed me first but I
want to share it with you now so then
you can feel clever as well so what I
need you to do is draw me another Circle
okay now with your second Circle you
might look at this and you might say Mr
that doesn't look like a semicircle to
me and that's true I've deliberately
drawn it to not look like a semicircle
because one of the dangerous things that
happens when you're doing a geometry
proof is things can look like something
and you can kind of fool yourself into
using logic that's not real because the
diagram looks like it right so I've
deliberately drawn something that's not
a semicircle
and what I want to say is let's imagine
there's some random chord A B
and what I want to prove is that it is
the diameter I don't know that it's the
diameter and that's why I've drawn it
looking weird okay but what I do know is
it's some random chord such that if I
find this other point p on the
circumference I get a right angle now
again you're going to say to me that
doesn't look like a right angle and the
whole point is I don't want to rely on
the diagram looking like that in order
to do my proof okay
so a b random chord P somewhere on the
circumference such that a PB a p b I
know that that's 90 degrees
so you might say that's that's given
and then the last construction that I
want to put on here is to say okay let's
call this point in the middle the
midpoint of a b now remember what I'm
aiming toward is that a b is the
diameter so if a b is the diameter then
what's special about the midpoint or the
diameter what what is that point
that's the middle of the circle yeah
very good I want to prove that m is the
center okay so I've actually just
noticed I've not drawn it very well so I
think I need to move it over a little
bit let me just make it a little more
looking like a midpoint I think that's a
that's a bit healthier okay fantastic
so I've got all the pieces of the puzzle
and now let's go let's go vectors on
this okay
now uh let's just put some arbitrary
things on here so if I start from my
midpoint right imagine that's a bit like
my origin if I go from the midpoint to
this capital a point over here let's
call that Vector a
now knowing that that's the midpoint
right what does that tell you about
going from the midpoint again what what
Vector would it be if I went to instead
of going to a what if I went to B what's
the relationship between those two
[Applause]
magnitude is the same at it last bit
again
um the magnitude is the same but they've
got different directions and they're the
equal better
okay fantastic so I know just be careful
I can't say radius just yet that's
that's right that's what I'm trying to
get to but but that's okay because it's
still a midpoint right exactly as you
said the magnitudes are identical it's
just the directions different not only
is the direction different it's
different in a very specific way can you
be more
um detailed for me what what difference
is there
uh like they're kind of going like this
right what does that tell you
that they're one they're one agrees like
yeah yeah they're not just different
they are in fact opposite so in terms of
the vectors I can actually say that's
that's the negative version of a do you
remember that's how we say go in the
opposite direction okay yeah
all right now I've got I've got a and
I've got negative a the last thing I've
got here is to get to that point on the
circumference um P right so this is a
different Vector okay let's call this I
guess because I'm going to capital P
let's call this Vector Little P all
right yep